-It's good to see you, bud. You look good.
-I love the Roots, man. -Yeah, you do?
I do. I love the Roots, too.
They're the greatest. Come on.
[ Applause ]
I have a lot of things I want to ask you.
First of all, thanks for being here.
You look great. -Thanks.
-Last time you were here, you were talking to me,
you said, "Jimmy." You got invited to the
Celebrity NBA All-Star Game,
and you said, "I'm taking it seriously.
I'm taking this seriously." -You want to bring that --
You want to bring that -- Why you wanna...?
-'Cause I kind of know the ending.
[ Laughter ]
You said you want to be MVP this year. You wanted --
Tell me exactly what you did again last time.
-So, at the time -- When I -- Before -- Okay.
So I got selected to play in the NBA Celebrity All-Star Game.
And, you know, me and my good friend Hannibal Buress, also.
-That's right. -We hired a basketball trainer
to get us ready for the game, right?
-Yeah. -So, I'm like, "Yo.
I'm about to get 15-5-5."
Right? That was the goal.
What happened was, uh, when I got to the game --
This is a true story. I got in the layup line.
And look, I'm in my 40s, man. You know what I mean?
-Wait. I'm sorry. The layup line?
-Let me tell you what happened. I was in the layup line.
And I felt a little twinge in my knee.
And in that moment, I made a decision.
I said, "Look, do you want to still be making movies?
Or be in crutches? What do you want to do?"
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God. -And so -- This is a true story.
I went to the locker room. I changed shoes.
I don't know why I -- Let me tell you something.
Anybody who plays basketball,
you know you need to break some shoes in.
I put on some fresh shoes.
-My gosh. This sounds like a nightmare.
-Okay, and then something crazy happened...
-Look. No big deal. It's just we have a clip.
-No, you don't.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's Lil Rel Howery at the Celebrity All-Star Game.
Take a look at this.
-Chance the Rapper's brother driving into traffic.
Yeah, tail -- Oh, no. I told you, I told you.
We're laughing about it. He's still dead serious.
Let's get the replay of what happened.
Here's Lil Rel go -- Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-No one around you! There was no one around you.
Rel! There was no one touching you.
-People don't realize how grippy the NBA floors are.
You know what I mean? -Grippy? The floors are grippy?
-They don't have pickup-game grip.
It's like NBA grip is totally different grip.
-So it's extra grippy? -It's extra grippy.
-So, when you're walking around --
So you're just gripped to the floor?
>> [Bleep]. It was so much grip.
-You just fell down. What happened?
-I'll tell -- Let me say this. I did take it way too serious.
I should have had more fun. Like, I was way too focused.
Like, even when they did the intros, I was like really --
You know, audience want to shake your hand.
I'm like, "No, I'm good."
You know, I'm chewing my gum all hard, so...
-Oh, my God. Ridic-- But you're such a funny guy.
Don't you want to just be -- -I don't know, man!
I always wanted to play in the NBA!
[ Laughter ]
-Did anyone give you any advice?
[ Laughter and applause ]
But Stephen A. Smith was your coach, right?
-Let me tell you. Stephen A. Smith is mean.
You know what I mean? Look, this is a celebrity game.
You're supposed to give everybody playing time.
But after the trip, he necessarily didn't want
to put me back in. [ Laughter ]
So I'm on the bench the whole time just looking at them.
I'm trying to be extra to everybody else.
"Y'all got this!"
-You're like, "Put me in, Coach."
-I'm just looking at them like a little kid.
I wish my dad was there. "Could you talk to him?"
-I want to talk about your special.
Congrats on this. -Thank you so much.
-"Lil Rel Howery: I Said It, Y'all Thinking It."
Great line. Where did the line come from?
-It really came from -- I did the Espys earlier this year,
and I made a joke about Tristan Thompson.
And the crowd was like "Ooh, ohh."
And I was like, "I said it! Y'all thinking it!"
[ Laughter ] And I was like,
"Wait a minute. That's a great name for a title!"
-Yeah, yeah. "That's the title of my special," yeah.
And you went to your hometown, went to Chicago.
-Went to Chicago. Shot it at the Chicago Theatre.
Both shows. Line around the corner.
-But then you also did a cool thing on top of that.
You paid for the entire audience's ticket.
-Yeah, I -- You know what's interest--
[ Cheers and applause ] Yeah, y'all -- It was free.
-That's gotta feel good, right?
-I mean, one of the reasons why I did it is --
First of all, I wanted it to be a gift to Chicago.
Because they -- Where I'm at now is because of Chicago.
All those, like, shows and hole-in-the-wall spots I did.
Those people came out and made sure --
They came to laugh, support me.
And it built my confidence and my comedy up.
And also, too, I'm like,
people feel happier when they don't pay.
Y'all happy, ain't y'all?
[ Cheers and applause ] They're happy. They are happy.
-They're happy when they don't pay.
-When it's free, people are happy.
-I want to show a clip, and this is the most friendly --
TV-friendly clip that we could show.
-I mean, look. I did a lot of cussing.
That's just what it is.
-Congrats, by the way, on the great reviews.
You're on, like, the top ten list
of every standup special out there right now.
So this is you, buddy. -Thank you so much.
I appreciate that. -That's what I'm talking about.
Here's a little peek at
"Lil Rel Howery: I Said It, Y'all Thinking It."
Take a look at this.
-You get some money, you be like,
"Oh, I ain't gonna have no roaches, 'cause I'm good now."
Mnh-mnh. Some new [bleep]. Ants!
[ Laughter ]
And they are worse than [bleep] roaches.
They work together [bleep].
You know, ants be marching together.
They be marching like a choir. [Bleep]
All through your bathroom. [Bleep].
You don't know where that pathway started!
I'm like, "Where the [bleep] y'all going?"
They got 15 fries. "Where the [bleep]
y'all find those fries at?!"
[ Laughter ]
♪ We're marching, we're marching up in your bathroom ♪
♪ That beautiful sink of God ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Lil Rel Howery, everybody!
His new special,
"Lil Rel Howery: I Said It, Y'all Thinking It,"
is streaming now on HBO Max.
We'll be right back with Clive Davis. Stick around.